french actor gaspard julio who was set
to appear in marvel's upcoming moon
night series on disney plus has died at
the age of 37 following a ski accident
according to multiple reports
according to french news agency afp
yulia was transported via helicopter to
a hospital in grenoble france after
suffering a head injury on a ski
mountain in the savoir region on tuesday
the afp reports that he later subcumbed
to his injuries and news of his death
was confirmed to the outlet by his
family via his agent on wednesday
on monday the first trailer for the
highly anticipated moon night series
dropped
i can't tell the difference
between my eyes and dreams
thank you
lost the contact lens hope you find it
thanks
in addition to his role as midnight man
in the marvel show yulio is known for
his work in french films like saint
laurent where he played the late fashion
designer take the
[Music]
he also starred in a very long
engagement and it's only the end of the
world
the actor also served as the face of the
fragrance blew de chanel and appeared in
an ad for the brand directed by martin
scorsese in 2010.
would you like her to rephrase the
question
i'm not going to be the person i'm
expected to be anymore
fueliel has won two caesar awards the
french equivalent of an oscar one for
best actor in 2017 for it's only the end
of the world and the other for most
promising actor in 2004 after starring
in a very long engagement
[Music]
born in the suburbs of paris in 1984
yulia began acting at a young age and
starred in several made-for-tv movies
during the 1990s and early 2000s and in
2011 he opened up to indiewire about
getting his start at age 11. quote i
then became interested in cinema as an
art form i think i developed little by
little a real passion for movies not
just acting for all those years i was
more attracted to being on set working
on set than being on a stage following
the news of his death french prime
minister jean gestex paid tribute to the
late actor on twitter writing in french
in part quote gaspard yulia grew up with
cinema and cinema grew with him they
loved each other madly
[Music]